In this section, we will explore the cloud-based MetaHuman Creator toolset.
Once you select Start MetaHuman Creator, select the engine version you wish to work in,
and then launch the MetaHuman Creator, it will take a few moments for the Creator to load.
Once our browser is finished loading, we can now see that we can create a MetaHuman using one of the presets.
If you have already created one, you will be able to find it in the My MetaHumans Gallery.
We will start by choosing a MetaHuman preset, and with this selected, on the bottom over here, we are going to click on Create Selected.
Now, let's get acquainted with the MetaHuman Creator interface.
Inside of this window, on the top left, we have our main menu with the name of our MetaHuman, which we can modify.
Right below, we have the Environmental and Quality toolbar.
We can control settings such as the environment by choosing from a variety of backgrounds and lighting presets.
Over here, we have the Camera View, where you can select six different camera presets, or use one to six on your keyboard to switch between them.
The Render Quality allows you to select the quality of lighting, hair, global illumination, and ray trace reflections.
Over here, you can view all of the available levels of detail for your MetaHuman.
The Toggle Clay Material replaces the skin texture with a clay-like material, making it easier to see the shape of certain facial features such as the eyes and lips.
The Toggle Hair enables and disables hair rendering.
And here, we have the hotkey reference on the right, and we can toggle this on and off if we wish.
Then, over here on the left, we have the Sculpting toolbar.
There is a Blend Mode, Sculpt Mode, and Move Mode.
The Attributes and Property selection allows you to select areas you want to customize.
And finally, we have the Animation toolbar, which is where you can control face and body animations that play on your MetaHuman in the Viewport.
Now that we are acquainted with the Viewport, let's explore some of the tools we have available to us starting with the Sculpting toolbar.
The Blend tool allows you to blend between three to six MetaHuman presets.
You can use the control points to change the shape of your MetaHuman's facial features.
Drag any MetaHuman preset to a slot on the Influence Circle.
I'm going to add Ada here, and then add Amelia over here, and Bernice over here.
The Blend Spaces allow you to blend per region.
If I move the control point on the nose closer to Ada, Ada's nose will blend with the nose of our MetaHuman.
I can also blend it with Amelia's nose or Bernice's nose.
Now, if you want to undo a change you have made, you can use this back arrow up here to revert back to the previous state.
Now, let's take a look at the Sculpt tool.
This allows direct manipulation with the finest level of control.
Think of this as an IK face control with the control points as the end effectors manipulating the geometry endpoints.
When this is enabled, two additional options become available.
Symmetry controls how to mirror edits from one side of the face to the other with the exception of the eyes.
You can mirror edits from left to right, right to left, or leave it set to average.
You can also turn symmetry off.
I will leave this set on and set it to average.
The Sculpting plane controls what view plane individual markers are moved in.
The Closest plane constrains the Sculpt markers to the front or side plane depending on which one of them is closest to the current camera angle.
This is enabled by default.
Take note of how the Sculpt marker moves when in this mode.
Now, let's switch to Screen plane.
This moves the Sculpt markers in a screen plane that is projected onto the 3D world from a particular camera angle.
We can see this moves a bit smoother in different directions.
And this has a similar functionality to some modeling applications such as Maya.
Now, let's take a look at the Move mode.
This allows us to make adjustments to broad regions of the face.
As I move this, we can see this allows us to move a group of markers at the same time.
And we can see what this looks like by using it to adjust the nose area.
Let's stop here for a moment and do a quick review of everything we've just covered before we move on.
We have become acquainted with the MetaHuman Creator interface and where all of our tools are located.
We've also gone through the Sculpting toolbar options.
Something to note about the Lend mode is that it overwrites any changes already made using the Sculpt or Move tool.
Moving a preset to a different slot or removing the preset will remove the influence from that preset region.
Now, the underlying system that drives the Sculpt and Move tools tries to find the closest combination of facial features of the real humans that have been scanned into the database
and it uses this to approximate what is being Sculpted.
When either the Sculpt or Move tool is selected, the Enable Symmetry and the Sculpt plane options will become available.
Now, let's move on by looking at the different attributes and properties we have available in the MetaHuman Creator.
The attributes and properties on the left over here are organized into three sections.
The face controls, the hair controls, and the body controls.
For the face controls, we have the skin, the eyes, the teeth, and makeup.
If we look at the skin tab, here we can customize the skin color and texture.
The skin color controls the skin tone and you can use the sliders at the bottom to control the picker position when choosing a shade.
The texture slider will allow you to control high frequency details in the textures.
This will also affect geometry and dynamic maps which are activated during facial expressions.
This is helpful if, for example, you wish to add details to the skin that indicate a character's age.
Moving on to the Freckles tab.
This has customization options that allow you to choose a freckle pattern.
You can also control the strength, density, saturation, and tone shift.
And then we have the accents tab.
This allows you to control the redness in specific areas of the face.
And this can be used to simulate different skin characteristics such as blushing, suntan, or sunburn, or dark circles under the eyes.
Now let's move on to the eyes where we have a lot of options.
By selecting a preset, this gives you a starting point for different eye colors and combinations.
The iris tab over here allows you to customize the eye details even further.
You can control the base and detail color of the eye and also truce from a blend method.
You can control the way colors are balanced and blended and you can even adjust the iris size, the saturation, and the limbous darkness.
The Sclera tab over here controls the white part of the eyes.
Here you can control things such as brightness, the vascularity, and even the veins rotation.
Now let's move on and look at the teeth properties.
I'm going to move our metahuman so we can get a closer look at the teeth.
Over here we have a visual representation of the teeth with nine adjustable controls.
We can adjust the control points to customize the tooth length, the tooth spacing, the upper shift or lower shift.
We can add an overbite or underbite and even modify the gums and the narrowness of the teeth.
We can also go through different variations of teeth.
Here we have the ability to change the tooth color.
We can change the gum color and even adjust the plaque color and plaque amount.
We can also open the jaw to get a better view of how these changes affect the teeth.
Finally we have the makeup properties.
I will reposition the face again so that we can see some of these options better.
Over here we have the option to choose from a few foundation presets.
Once we check this on we can adjust the concealer intensity under the eyes.
We can also fine tune the intensity and roughness of the foundation.
The eyes tab contains pre-made styles for combining eyeliner and eyeshadow.
This has its own color options and you can control the roughness, the transparency and the metalness.
The blush adds blush to the cheeks and you can select how blush is applied to the face.
You can create your own custom color or choose from a variety of presets.
You can also control its intensity and roughness.
For the lips you can apply pre-made lipstick styles and also control the color, the transparency and the roughness.
Now before we move on to the hair controls let's do a review of everything we have covered.
For the skin properties we can use the skin tab to access customizations such as the skin color and textures.
The texture option is a very powerful tool as it affects geometry and dynamic maps.
The freckles tab gives you the ability to add more detail to the skin.
You can select from a freckle pattern and customize things such as the strength and density of the freckles.
The accents tab which controls redness in specific areas of the face can be used to simulate different skin characteristics such as blushing,
sun tan, sunburn or dark circles under the eyes.
For the eye properties you can get a starting point with one of the presets.
The iris tab gives you control over the color and iris details.
And the sclera tab controls the white part of the eyes and you can adjust things such as the brightness and vascularity.
You can also adjust the left and right eyes separately.
For the makeup properties you can apply foundation and concealer.
And you can choose from a variety of pre-made styles for eye makeup, blush and lipstick each with their own customizable properties.
If you are using a medicuman for fashion for instance, these makeup properties can save you a lot of time instead of having to add these types of details using other DCCs.
The teeth properties come with 9 adjustable controls and we can even tailor the color of the teeth and skin tone of the gums.
Now that's it for this section.
Next we will continue exploring the medicuman creator by looking at the hair controls.